two oh no
oh no james charles
just last night as i was prepping this
podcast out of nowhere
wasn't even on my radar first 30 seconds
of the episode be careful
i i know anyway this episode is
sponsored by harry's
which is incidentally they're probably
not going to like this but
all right you guys know where i'm going
with this so i was prepping the show
last night we had all this fun stuff to
talk about
and of course james charles comes back
again with a new
um a new [ __ ]
boy he's
and we're talking here we go like god do
we need to do another content chord on
james charles and
ian's ian goes dude this is no time for
content court this is time for a real
court
and you make a great point this is not a
laughing matter this is a
why does nobody care there's a serious
predator
he's out there his name is james charles
and he is preying on children
this 15 year old kid
which is like i'm chris hanson like
dateline nbc
chris thank you just the man i'm looking
for which is
a b this is this is right six he's been
exposed
six times oh no six fans
exposed him in the last six months four
of them
not in the last six months really i
thought that was over like the
the lifetime of his illustrious career
of uh hitting fans
no this is in the last six months
there's been four minors
jesus because i remember when we did the
james charles content court there were
some
because the the really the only
allegation against him was from
tata tati tati
tata and we were like that's just too
thin to make such a strong accusation so
we dropped that whole
aspect but since we made that
six fans have
have allegedly have been send
receiving james
for take a seat right over there
you know like and
i'm going crazy over here nobody gives a
[ __ ] he's out here being like hi
sisters
and i've i don't know my sister listen
yeah i i guess i'm pro if if i want to
cancel
james charles if that makes me pro
cancel culture then i guess i am
this is like there's this idea that like
cancel culture is so evil nobody
deserves to be canceled
james charles deserves to be cancelled
wow sister snapped adolf hitler deserved
to be canceled
let's start there so some cancellations
are justified right
well can you even really call it a
cancelling at this point
it's kind of like the it's similar with
the david thing it's like was david
really canceled
or did credible allegations of actual
crimes come out like where does the line
really between canceling
and you know culpability for for for
committing it for committing an actual
crime well that's a great point and i
feel like
people's these the first of all the
whole
and the whole like we all know that pc
culture has gone too far
we're all fed up with it we're all on
the same page
but there is this movement fueled by
what i
perceive as strong conservative and
probably
a lot of white nationalism kind of thing
coming in as i don't know if that that's
how i perceive it
okay [ __ ] you that's my opinion
[Applause]
come on down here now we want our
freedom for the world
who are saying now oh what i can't be
racist
cancel culture everything's cancelled
culture
nobody could be held accountable for
having shitty opinions
but that's that's i guess my point is
like i feel like there
is a strong line to be drawn between
people being cancelled for opinions and
uh beliefs which you know that you can
have a debate about the merits of that
but then that gets conflated with again
people
actually doing illegal things like
that's not
when people say like oh cancel culture
run amok talking about
again david i'm just bringing up because
this is very prominent recent example
um you know i i don't think that the
label of canceling even really applies
there it's uh
you know he's not i think you're right
and first of all dan thank you for
switching to yourself
trying to get better about not make me
looking at my when i'm talking [ __ ]
james charles i've been making these
bomb
ass mother loving tic there's some weird
conspiracy going on on tick tock about
james charles i
[ __ ] you not i make these great tick
talks about james and they get removed
so fast
that's snoop right or is that that's
yeah i believe that's the same
yeah thank you they get removed so fast
do you know how much content is uploaded
about james charles let me show you for
example
my most recent one that i posted
yesterday i was like oh this thing is
such a banger
oh no oh you know what i'm sorry i'm
getting ahead of myself let's watch the
new tick tock of the expose
so this is i don't know why these i
don't know why
these guys make their videos so awful
it's like they're trying not to anyone
to watch so you have to
pause it and i guess muted too so he
sent him this that would be so cute
oh see it's like i know i was blown away
by this it's like what is he doing
everything is on screen for two frames
and then it cuts to something else
i i can't do this guy you guys are gonna
have to
go you should just show how insane it is
though yeah
i love too when he's showing the
messages he's just like scrolling around
randomly like everything's
like pearl come on he's like i just i
love it
it's my home i love these shirtless yeah
what
there's something about exposed video
while you're shirtless that's just
magical
yeah at first i was like i had to
decrypt this i was like what am i and
then i
was able to um i was like oh okay i get
this now here see i keep missing it
tick tock is literally on screen for a
half a second i guess it's on beat
though it's on beat it's pretty dope the
way he did it on beat but oh
i can't [ __ ] actually read it so sick
yeah really sad
i'm really sad okay i'm gonna preempt
this
okay here we go here we go here we go
i can't do this can somebody just send
me a screenshot
i believe um one of you put together uh
the screenshots
let's see i'm i'm saving it right now
wouldn't this be funny if this is the
tick tock that gets james canceled
you can't even [ __ ] read it anyway
sister it's like you're doing the screen
record you don't like don't
randomly scroll up and down while you're
uh
trying to i think he's trying to show
the authenticity of the
i suppose you know what i mean i made
this tick tock yesterday about james
charles
it was popping off okay and i tagged
them
okay and it was immediately removed oh
this is my conspiracy video
nobody cares about that here
this was from the subreddit somebody
said they found this
this job uh posting for any audio at the
end
james charles if you're watching this
um i found a
employment opportunity for you here
uh somebody let yeah james
okay removed for harassment and bullying
thoughts someone's protecting him
i mean and do you i mean you usually
have an even head on this like
do you think this qualifies as
harassment and bullying
james
be honest give me a level-headed
response here wait can i get to play by
play one more time
charles if you're watching this
um i found a
employment opportunity for you here
uh somebody let yeah james
i mean it sounds like you're just
looking out for him john that's what i'm
saying
like i know i'm trying i'm exactly
and so i was like okay maybe it was
popping off and then after my
nine minutes it was removed okay so i
thought to myself okay you know
[ __ ] this i'm gonna post it again maybe
it's because i tagged james
so i posted again with no tags or
anything and it got removed in one
minute
that's impossible unless some like
somebody's monitoring right on tick tock
the enormity
of content being uploaded i mean what
the hell
i mean it could be a swarm of of fans
that just mass report anything too i'm
sure that doesn't help
i think he's got an inside guy nine
minutes though that's
that's very quick i mean yeah it was so
i don't know
trisha says the same thing happens to
her too like she doesn't even talk about
him anymore because
because she says anytime she mentions
james charles
it gets removed and i mean like trisha
and me with peace and love
we are we talk [ __ ] about a lot of
people on tick tock
you know what i mean and i've never had
this happen
so i don't know it probably does you
know how it goes
i mean every time anybody uploads
content about you you just hit up susan
and then
they've got a surgical though surgical
strike team and that's why
that's why it feels funny because i've
been on the receiving end of
such conspiracy theories but yeah
i mean he's in with the demilios and all
those that's
true that's right
also to go off of that one of his
alleged victims got banned from tick
tock after making one of their exposed
videos on him
that was weird now what now for sure he
was banned or did he erase his account
uh he was for sure banned because he
tweeted about it too
wow unless he was lying unless he was
lying i have not confirmed with
tick-tock
he could be something to be totally fair
because he's i don't know you never know
he's got some godfather like sleeps with
the fishes [ __ ] man
who's the ceo tencent
tencent well that's the parent company
right
listen tim talk zach keep away from that
yeah
don't do it i have it right on the don't
do it zach
this is james how dare you allow anybody
to go against the family do you know who
i am the demilious
i have looked at a thousands of little
boys
armpit hair hi sisters
how dare you allow this man to call me a
[Music]
groomer
they lie to me about their age but
trust me i don't check that odd
you broke my heart how am i
the groomer i'm the victim i point out
that ian
and abe have left wait everybody's
leaving
[Music]
you guys suck man this is funny
you guys really hit me like that i love
it no i seen ian do it so i just i
wanted to add on to this
follow the leader hey you go against the
family
you're breaking my heart baby ian i
expect this disrespect for me
he's a laughing he's a good friend he
makes jokes haha
funny man clown but eb
you broke my heart
i apologize don klein all right what the
[ __ ] we doing
let's talk about james charles thank you
zack
zack always got my back always
he's the golden boy he's the golden boy
his hair ain't just gold his heart is
too
hmm oh that's very sweet i copied your
bald head now too
[Music]
no i didn't what i just no i just really
missed yeah ab shaved his head
on i got it no i messed it up like bad
but it's this is why i should not be
hear you
wait let me see your hair it's like
completely
bro
oh no yeah i'll be wearing a hat for a
few months
why'd you do that i i was trying to even
it out
you took it a little too far you were
sipping dude
you were sipping mm-hmm but he didn't
you were going to shave your head like
ethan oh my god
s-i-m-p well hey you want bro you well
you gotta buzz it all now i mean you
can't even walk you can't walk around
like that
i don't go anywhere i mean i'm home all
day she's gonna wear a hat
dude please buzz it off what's wrong
with you everyone was talking about how
beautiful your hair looked
i got problems i do this a lot i don't
know
i think i have some kind of problem like
i can't same thing if i have like
acne on my face i can't just leave it i
have to
play with it at it yeah now you're bald
now i'm bald well we wish you the best
shout out to your family can we focus on
james charles we have a literal predator
in our meds
all right i want to look at this kid's
tick tock who's who's going to help me
with this
okay we have um hacked into the
mainframe to decode his
tick tock so this is in sequential order
yes oh my god okay bro
all right so apparently what happened
was they were chatting
in notice he wishes him a happy birthday
because james will try to
say that he didn't know his age as if
that even matters let's be honest
like that's such a red herring the point
is not even that you
he lied about his age it's that anyone
can lie to you about their age bro why
are you talking to all these people
i mean four of them have been minors and
you're still doing it you absolute
[ __ ] lunatic i'll just be your secret
lover
right well that's kind of what he says
here so he james wishes him a happy
birthday he had just turned 16.
so deaf noodles who we love again just
to
even though again it doesn't matter did
james charles know
he wished the 15 year old boy happy
birthday
on november 2020
[Music]
oh you lied the kids literally typing 15
year old everywhere
you lied to me oh no
how did i get tricked once again
so now anyway so he says happy birthday
apparently he posted a picture of their
conversation on his instagram story
and then james flips on him what the
[ __ ] is your problem
what the [ __ ] is your let me what the f
hi sister i'm trying to get the gym what
the [ __ ] is your problem the [ __ ] is
your what the
freak what the heck what the [ __ ] is
your problem
it's just it's really hard it's so hard
because i don't want to just make a
stereotypical gay
i mean that's how he talks though i know
it's troubling
that is so true what the [ __ ] is your
problem posting screenshots of
my snaps to you on your private story
i strongly recommend that you keep
my name out of your mouth or we're gonna
have a major problem
uh oh do i smell james getting scared
that somebody's exposing him talking to
his
minor like why do you care that much
hi sisters because oh no
i'd love to remind you that you are the
one who called
me cute and said you were bisexual and
then into me
oh the kid came up to me
that's it the kid came on to me i mean
what can i do
this is literally doing he's literally
saying that the kid came on to me
yikes he said hold up
i don't know get a life and respect
people's privacy
he's telling this kid to get a life now
you're just 16 years
people's privacy i'm sorry james what
privacy
are we supposed to respect when you're
talking to children you're back battling
because you got caught who got caught
here dude
oh no oh no
he said we already talked about this
that's a complete lie you idiot
you're backpedaling because you got
caught uh who got caught
james uh chris hanson like that sister
dude i swear god this is a [ __ ]
conversation from to catch a predator
like you this is literally a plot line
from a chat room from to catch a
predator
james is walking in the [ __ ] kitchen
right now to meet this kid
and it's chris hanson it's no different
what was on the agenda tonight
exactly
don't ever speak to me again i added you
and rem and mine did my own i added you
okay once again you have like 20 million
followers and you're adding specific
like
kids always on snapchat by the way
which is like predators basically has
just turned into the
celebs preying on fans app
right i mean that i'm pretty sure that's
all snapchat is used for now
you seem pretty confident on the
internet
don't ever speak to me again i added you
and i did my own business until
you called oh then he threatens him
wait i think something's missing here
but he says it's against the law what
you're doing by the way
okay james sister what law
the share dms is against the law yeah
apparently
i i don't know what what what he said i
think it was something about lying about
your age oh yeah
he he lied about his age which is
against the law well
i'm pretty sure we know who's the one
breaking the law here
which messages did i leave the message
of you admitting you lied about your age
i saved them and they're gone
oh no that's it
yeah well by the way it's not illegal to
lie about your age
it's not against the law so so it is so
he's bowling intimidating a lot he's
basically just floundering
because he wants to put a cap on this
the guy's got a problem i mean the guy
needs help
he has happened four miners in the last
six months
he can't stop the man needs help
the man needs a sister just be your
secret lover
the man needs some sister sessions with
a therapist
wow sister snapped oh [ __ ] i shouldn't
put this on mine hang on down
what did you say maybe oh that was just
the part that was missing here
yeah get your [ __ ] friend in line
before i do
lying about your age is bait to someone
and it's against the law by the way
flying against your age debate someone
is against the law by the way that's
appreciated i don't think it is that's
that's the premise
to catch a predator the whole yeah right
and the the onus is on the adults in
this situation wait no that's not true
they're lying about being younger but
still lying about the age
of course the only adult and in this
case not even the adult this guy who is
a
powerful influencer who's talking to his
fans it's sick
it's [ __ ] up it keeps happening brands
keep working with him
people keep associating with him noah
back literally even
after one of the uh one of these stories
just came out said i love james charles
so it's time to
call out these people who are enabling
this
to happen all the demons
i know charlie's a girl so but like char
charlie's very young i i don't put any
blame on charlie but dixie's an adult
her [ __ ] parents they like we're just
hanging out two days ago with the
demilio family
what parents would let them their
children around this
pr predator
noah back is down with james charles he
loves james charles
no back you're enabling
no back this is you enabling a a uh
a predator go ahead dan i got no audio
sister james been holding up with all
the controversy i
love james cool nice well i hope you
love him as much as james loves
six-year-old armpit shots
what was on the agenda tonight
love james can you imagine like going up
to quentin tarantino after like uh
the heart the weinstein [ __ ] tell me
what do you think about weinstein
listen love weinstein
oh my god this is the t nobody gives a
[ __ ]
brands did still work with james
chipotle
morph morph is like cosmic it's all
cosmetic
chipotle the spring chicken uh
where there's some other good ones did
anyone ever have any some good burrito
names for jams
the drink chicken is good i feel like
there's better ones though too
i remember on uh friday when you were
asking this um
somebody said uh james gets veal
and his uh v and his burrito
some bougie-ass chipotle but you know
because veal is like baby cow so yeah
yeah yeah yeah
this is a little spooked
uh chipotle
is con sponsoring him morph cosmetics is
sponsoring
at this point a basically alleged
okay alleged we say alleged
in quotes because
let's be [ __ ] honest it's been
alleged by enough people by now
how many people got to allege the same
thing with receipts okay
morph cosmetics lily lashes what is that
[ __ ]
sometimes i'm sure it's a cosmetic
eyelashes
morphe too by the way oh it is well they
probably make so much money from him
lily lashes yeah
would look good on any predator
they have actually a lily lashes
actually if you guys go
dollyash.com predator
they have a special package to help you
pick up 16 year old boys
[Music]
so let lilly lashes know
hashtag slash predator
oh it didn't work oh dead ended okay my
bad
i mean am i going i'm not going too far
right like this is literally
i everybody's been i have been screaming
from the top of the [ __ ] mountains
this guy is dangerous and at a certain
point you have to let it go but it keeps
happening
yeah yeah i mean how we gonna how are we
gonna protect
members of our young community who are
being thrown to the wolves
by brands like laura's boutique laura
[ __ ] you what is laura's boutique
young women's fashion oh boy
here you get 30 right now it says on
laura's batik you get 30
off your entire order if you use code lb
loves you
i also heard you get 30 off if you type
james charles
uh james charles solicited nudes from me
when i was under age
i'll put that link in the description
zach hitting you with that sounds so
funny so
shout out to wow they have one model for
everything
interesting oh maybe it's laura that's
laura oh laura's killing it this is her
whole store
i don't know i'm curious because that's
pretty
anyway laura shout out for that promo
called james charles is a predator and
sends me armpit pics
ask for um
community is this one to call out i
don't know if that's something that like
you just signed up for
but he has a community number which we
called communities this thing where
you can put your number in so [ __ ]
people can harass you on your phone like
jesus christ i will die before i get a
community
don't quote me on that i see like a year
from now or something teddy fresh having
like a community thing
yeah it could be useful for fans yeah
don't so don't quote me on that i signed
up for one and
it it's the worst decision i made about
was it porn zach tell me what was no no
no no it was
actually dr aegis oh you did the dr
aegis
dude there's such liars about that [ __ ]
dr aegis is such a [ __ ] liar what is
that he goes on howard stern
he goes wow it's his real number and he
answers everybody i'm like you are a
[ __ ] liar yeah yeah it's just i mean
it's not super rapid i'd say it's every
twice a week but it just
it's kind of annoying and the
information that he's providing isn't
really
it's awesome yeah yeah yeah so what's in
it for him
do you try to sell you [ __ ] no it's just
like oh here's the covets just keeping
people updated
yeah and it's all like something
yeah it's all the showmen so [ __ ] the
pitch is coming
yeah yeah yeah i got suckered into it
well anyway james [ __ ] has a
community number on his instagram page
let's look
and he even he even says we called him
on friday
he goes hi sisters i might even send you
a selfie if you sign up i was like oh
god hi sisters oh no did he remove it no
it's on his twitter
ozone it's not instagram oh
[ __ ] phone number it's like everybody
chill dude i don't need to connect
anymore
we need to connect more faster oh yeah
text me sisters
so how much more do i need to connect
with you guys i'm here
i'm here all the time
this is all i do
no more connecting can you imagine why
would i even text you guys
probably like oh a new video you don't
need that
you know where to find me
hey we're uh we're at break time all
right
let's take a break and we'll be right
back
harry's razors yes
too often we find ourselves choosing
between quality
and a fair price but with harry's you
have to choose no more they're gonna
give you an award-winning blade at
factory direct prices
[Music]
i love harry's i don't use
i don't do much shaving i just do the
back of my neck you know i'm in the
shower
works great there i know eli uses it in
the shower for her legs
and she loves it but it's just it's a
girthy
blade it just feels like a quality
product you know
we love that we love that about hairs
[Music]
for a limited time hairs is offering
their starter set
plus free body wash for just three
dollars
excuse me did i read that right three
dollars
at harry's dot com sound more enthused
they'll be yawning and saying wow
wow you go that is an amazing deal my
mic was muted so nobody would have even
known that until you called it out three
dollars that is an amazing deal
there's a graveyard.com h3 you know
what's the best thing about going to
harrys.com
h3 not only are you gonna get this
incredible
starter set plus free body watch you're
also gonna support the show
incredible why are you gonna choose
harry's well let me tell you
close comfortable shave at a fair price
it's only two dollars per refill
harry's believes in quality so much they
brought they bought their own factory in
germany
so they could own every step of the
manufacturing process
how do they do it harry's team combines
a simple ergonomic design with five
sharp blades
they source their steel from sweden we
got the swedes we got the germans we got
all we got the brightest mines in europe
all come together
to make a [ __ ] blade
god damn it harry's german factories
want to select few manufacturers in the
world that have mastered the technology
to create a gothic arc
wow the gold standard for razor blade
grinding
gothic arc folks nobody can
bend steel like them apparently it's
like the
attorio hanzo what'd you call that and
kill build the hot tori hanzo blade yeah
they have the hattori hanzo
of razor blades they got a 100
guaranteed
quality guarantee they stand behind
their blades so much
that listen 100 money back guarantee
nothing to lose it's that simple it's
that honest
harrys.com h3 for a limited time harry's
has an exclusive offer for our listeners
new customers can get hairy starter set
and free body wash for just three
dollars yes
three dollars at harry's dot com slash h
street
that's over 16 of value for just three
dollars you're gonna get
five blade razor a weighted handle
foaming
shave gel a travel cover a travel sized
body wash
it's an incredible deal but act fast
while supplies last
go to harrys.com h3 to redeem your offer
we're back is it is um jim charles
trending
oh it is good thank god last night when
i s when this news broke i was like oh
oh no it's not nobody's gonna care again
so here he's trending i think i just put
out a tweet oh yeah
sorry oh good trish isn't on until
we love her
i says james charles a predator just
trying to get his name trending y'all
let's go
i also tweeted last night like at 3am
when i was prepping for the show
james charles caught with yet another 15
year old boy i swear to god yelled is
getting [ __ ] ridiculous call anyone
out they associate
calls anyone out who associates with
this man i am losing my mind
i'm chris hanson that's seven likes so
take it with a pinch of salt but
why are you holding on to this the kids
are lying about their age
and some about orientation
trapping gay men is pretty sick oh wow
turning it into a victim thing he's the
victim
that's that being said james is not
innocent he needs to be held accountable
for his actions
there's no proof that he actively
seeking underage boys
come on how deluded can you be
well they're probably really young
come on and then dude there's literally
everybody now
it's crazy now all these all of his fans
are going to try to like
assassinate this poor kid's character
and turn it into this whole thing about
how
this kid is a liar and at 12th grade he
once got suspended from school for
smoking weed in the parking lot
he once made a tick-tock he wouldn't
even be in 12th grade yet
right it's a good point what he was
he made a tick tock six months ago where
he joked about
uh he joked about asian food i don't
know you know what i mean like it's like
they try to ruin his [ __ ] life
because he got preyed upon like here
this person says
it's us that this kid says i never
delete anything but snapchat says he
deleted messages who gives a [ __ ]
it's like it doesn't matter if he lied
about his age
that's so beside the point and anyway as
we pointed out literally with two
seconds of research james knows he's 15
so stop it i'll make it feel really good
for you
han he has this habit of aligning
himself with these big creators
that he's a shield sound bite you keep
those commented
you got it i'm sorry ab what
no i'm sorry i i was just saying he has
this habit of like aligning himself with
these big creators
so that he has these people supporting
him with massive audiences and he uses
them as like a shield
anytime there's any controversy anyone
says anything about charlie or dixie or
anyone he's always the first one to jump
in and defend them
and he acts as if it's him being a good
friend but
i think it's more to protect himself
yeah he got in good with those demilios
man
basically god fathered them
i wonder if they seen his armpit hair
probably
you believe i swear to god he asked one
of these kids
for
on god hand to god saw this
i mean right that's what he asked for
the screenshots are out there
get find it fact check me yeah thank you
this
is a little spooky
[ __ ] hell uh let's see in the last
six months james has been exposed for
talking to four
the newest accuser was in the first
message
the one we've been talking about this
other one alleged he was 21 years old
sent him unsolicited nudes on snapchat
oh so james sent this guy unsolicited
nudes on snapchat
right a b allegedly
allegedly assaiya
so this this kid says he's 21 so james
like oh well here's my dick
allegedly on snapchat which we know is
the
fake bro if you're on snapchat you're
going to get you
you're going to get assaulted you can
pretty much count on it
i mean i don't understand what the
[ __ ] going on on that app
if a celebrity asks you to add them on
snap you're gonna you're about to get
assaulted
wow sister snapped it's crazy bro
so anyway he sent this 21 year old his
dick on snapchat allegedly and pressured
him to reciprocate
despite him telling him he was only 16.
love that here's def noodles recedes you
know he's like got him
oh apparently this kid was banned from
tick tock this was the one
yeah jesus
can't even do this anyway it's an
accuser
you know um going back to the armpit
hair
i'm seeing a tweet of his from uh
a long time ago saying that someone
asked to see his armpit hair on a meagle
that's all you found it's only fun keep
looking
i swear to god there's a text where you
asked
dude i swear the the last guy who we
we talked about who he was like super uh
aggressive with
there was videos of him and everything
he's like why don't you just why don't
you just send
and stuff and he was in the bathroom and
all this okay
i like i'm telling you
so that's the other one this all
happened six months span keep going
another user named anon j
reportedly claimed that he was 17 when
charles reached out
though nothing sexual occurred even so
they recalled thinking it was
weird that charles was flirting
yeah i'd say that i like to make love
let's see
let's look through here yeah like i'm
sorry james charles has 20 million
followers on instagram and he's just
randomly chatting up
a fourth accuser going by the handle of
life of
fousey posted several tweets in an
eight part series about his interaction
with charles on tick tock
and claimed he was also asked for nude
photos according to life of fousey he
contacted charles on instagram
after the youtubers highly politicized
2019 feud with tata
tati tata westbrook
who weirdly is proven to be right about
her accusations like can we talk about
tati like she was [ __ ] right that he
is a weirdo
oh what was her i thought your whole
thing was he
ate the wrong vitamins and she was well
well
that was kind of the in between the line
no her her main accusation was
ugh that's [ __ ] amazing but that's
true
because it probably can't control
himself he knows he's [ __ ] up
you know when you send this message and
and the amount of times that this is
like right at this point like does he
have like a humiliation fetish or
something no he has
no he that is so true
he he cannot help himself he cannot
stop yes
you know man i saw this crazy
documentary
about uh i think it was a louis thoreau
one where he was
looking at all these convicted sex
criminals
and just like learning about them and
stuff
love louis thoreau there was this one
guy just kind of
it's an extreme example but something
that stood with me
he was chemically castrated by the
government
because he our yeah i think it was
ordered to be chemically casual is this
in the uk
it might have been because that sounds
they used to do that i think
he couldn't he couldn't stop exposing
himself
he wouldn't he could not stop but so
eventually they gave him
some chemical castration to like reduce
his libido so he couldn't get it up and
stuff
and he's like he's like do you do it
since you've been chemically castrated
he says yes i do
i still do it he couldn't help himself
he couldn't stop
people like semen right
oh here we go we got another one okay
you guys
listen i bet you can make me finish by
just
flexing and showing off your body hair
i'm gonna come bro he sent this message
you guys
i bet you can make me finish by just
flexing and showing off your body hair
why did he say oh body your hair
parentheses
body hair without even taking your dick
out
so he likes flexing and showing off that
body
hair bruh i can't
oh was that the cat
zoom guy yeah
he has not responded to my armpit shot
by the way
are you flexing i was not flexing
that was the problem yeah that's where
you [ __ ] up
james and you know it's like
here's the thing he's rich he's famous
i'm sure james could get all the tail he
wants
but he continues to go to the fans he
continues to dip
in to these very young questionable i'm
sorry dude if you go on instagram
you can tell the difference between a
[ __ ] 25 year old and a 15 year old
sorry 99 of the time i'll give a one
percent exception so but this has
happened eight times
yeah really sad yeah i mean
like you said the the guy is extremely
successful wealthy
um you know what grinder
tinder whatever you know what i mean
like why why
why fans on snapchat like what what
purpose is that serving he can't help
himself he's a danger
to himself and and to and to those
around him
you know what i mean
it's crazy oh so back to so tati said
she was originally calling him out
because he was constantly
pressuring straight men
into hooking up with him or something
she was saying she wasn't responsible
right
but but what triggered it she said is
that he used he went against her gummy
which i promoted the wrong gummies she
yeah she was saying she basically took
him in her and her husband
and then he promoted the competition's
brand
and it was a slap in the face because he
literally just posted a story
because they helped him at coachella or
something like she lost her [ __ ] mind
she just like went
full nuclear tried to destroy her life
but didn't they didn't they uh
make amends and then unite to uh destroy
shane yeah they will lie which is funny
because now
she's so stupid because now she's right
but she's
ruined it by making amends with james to
unite against shane
this [ __ ] is avengers level weird like
the alliances and the
moving pieces i mean this is a whole
multi-universe
that was an all-timer apology when she
came out we've been talking about
you know apology tier lists recently
from youtube right there was so much to
i remember there was like bamboo yeah
yes all kinds of things was so legit
reason holy jet
that was that was the last tier for sure
that's your apology
i heard her she went like bankrupt and
stuff
i don't know like her whole vitamin [ __ ]
went under and thanks to james
and torpedoed in her whole business
well she was clearly it's just like lady
if your whole business hey guys welcome
to today's
sorry if your whole business strategy is
counting on
james charles to promote it then you
[ __ ] are
making a huge mistake breaking my
silence
my business went uh bankrupt because
james charles wouldn't promote my gummy
that's the last video she made holy [ __ ]
she was sued by the co-founder of her
beauty vitamin company
oh my god drama
so they're in some real [ __ ] you know
what i love when youtubers go
new video every week monday and thursday
at 10am pst
and then they're uploading nine months
i don't have anything like that on my
banner do i i better check
no
[Laughter]
um i intentionally never put that
because
you never really like stuck to a
schedule yeah i didn't want to be that
guy
new videos every thursday at the front
tuesday and thursday at 10 a.m
nope no tattoo's house went for sale
um last month went on the market what'd
you get for it
it's listed for four million oh damn
girl what's up
how's it look nice stuff um
yeah sherman oaks sherman tokes
sure nice today's [ __ ] nice
uh i wonder if that's like um
they need the money situation or if
they're just bailing out of la situation
well i think she lives in seattle i
think she has another oh
oh yeah she's balling why do you why do
you know that
i don't do this it's my job what like to
know where tati lives
question yeah i mean does she well but
he didn't look at that he didn't look it
up he just
opened me he just knows i know that
he is right he is right there you go
zach i wasn't really doubting that you
were right
listen i never doubted that he was right
i was questioning why he knows i think
it is a funny
question though that you did happen to
just know that
i was curious why he why he knew it too
so
sorry zack i'm with dan on this one it's
just an odd little piece of trivia to
have just sitting in there i don't know
i i know it man i mean
i don't i don't know what board is there
which part of seattle she lives in
no i don't know that
yeah i mean i'm a big grunge fan so
um let's see there's more
according to the uh
yeah yep
oh this was a good one face sway a
famous
gamer
just revisiting the classics it's from
last year in july
you kind of look good
you ain't seen nothing do you see the
flames kind of gotta kill
jake's butt and then he goes oops
he re-erased it because oops i think
about i had no idea you're
sorry left my ass off sister hit me up
on snapchat
i'll just be your secret lover
i mean this is amazing right
this is a real interaction it's hard to
believe
oops oh there it is
[Laughter]
we miss you hila ah
so
james charles videos are being removed
from tick tock people are trying to talk
about it
tick tock's like his biggest platform he
is
massive on tick tock and nobody can talk
about him here's another banger ass
tweet i made about james congratulations
that was
erased for bullying and harassment now
you tell me is this bullying and
harassment
jason james charles on your kids choice
award
it's perfect because i know that kids
have always been your choice so
that works out perfectly ops nickelodeon
keep an eye on him during the after
party
bullying harassment i mean
by the letter of the law yeah probably
by the letter of
which law i did i mean there probably is
by which it's okay to bully some people
oh i see you're saying okay
but you're bullied like who just no no
law
it's a figure of speech i'm just saying
yes you
you are you are bullying somebody you
are bullying me okay
am i bullying james charles by making
one
i think bullying is more like the like
let's
say it's the repetitiveness like i
hadn't made a video about james charles
i mean
hold on how many videos hold on no no
back on tick tock when i posted this
video
i had not talked about james charles
okay um this was a one-off
video that i posted
you are bullying me i believe you may
have but a lot a lot
like in november probably but it was
only i think one other tick tock
about let's all please reflect on the
fact that james charles
who has had six credible allegations of
in the past six months won a kid's
choice award
yes hilarious and on the same night that
david was hosting right
that it was a cursed kid's choice award
that may go down as the most
cursed case choice choice ever that's
like bill cosby and weinstein have like
i accepting this award on behalf of bill
cosby who couldn't be here tonight
i missed the mark with that one
oh ian corrected me he said i had a
bunch of tick tocks about james
stillington yeah
yeah okay fine
but like where is this is it this is
like a totally appropriate joke
so it's like no other than some [ __ ]
that i got removed and you
you might be right he's a top creator on
tick tock he might have some pull
to uh he's got almost suppressed
criticism
of him he's in man though i mean
all jokes aside we we know how absurd
the whole narrative about you having a
hotline to susan is
or whatever right right and tick tock is
an even bigger like
uh i mean can you really even get a hold
of anybody at tik tok
i have someone at tick tock they reached
out to me oh well get him to delete
james charles account well i messaged
him
i did message him i was like yo why are
these videos keep getting removed and he
didn't
answer that question suspicious
suspicious i don't know i'm just i i i
agree
i don't think he's like call he's it's
not like james is calling someone every
time there's a video about him but like
there seems to be some type of
moderation going on
and deaf noodles got locked out of his
twitter as well when he shared one of
the videos
yeah twitter don't give a [ __ ]
he got locked out for 12 hours uh when
you post a video about one of the
victims of james
weird what twitter twitter is like down
for
anything you could do like beheading
videos on twitter and they're cool with
that [ __ ]
nothing twitter world this is yours i
mean they've
they've gotten they've gotten more uh
what are the i didn't know there were
any rules here
i mean pornography is totally fine
pornography is fine but uh
are they not down with violence yeah i
mean they got a lot of bad
press this was a while ago now yeah i
mean
when um when all of those isis videos
were all over
twitter and they were getting a ton of
[ __ ] they finally kind of cracked down
on all that
isis had like a huge presence on twitter
so ironic isis got us so good
because they caused the adpocalypse on
youtube
right because youtube was putting ads on
isis videos
and isis was making round and they
[ __ ] up twitter because people were
posting
ice like they actually got us
dude isis videos
it's kind of i mean they kind of mission
accomplished us
they were trying to destroy our destroy
our culture
our heritage
say what you will about isis but it's my
god-given american right
um hold on it's my
god-given american right to fight
to defend the right to where
ugh did you see the karen today that was
wearing a see-through mask
nope oh no oh god it was so funny maybe
it's on tick-tock
i was hoping it would just show up it's
my god-given right to protect
people from wanting to spread kovid
whatever
no no i'm out i'm out going
thank you though thanks for teaming me
up i was just i wasn't there
so that's it james made a statement
last month uh admitting
right i mean i'm just going to re-going
over this because i think it's important
you know admitting to it well that's all
i pretty much have to say about that
that's all huh i do want to mention
everyone that this episode is sponsored
by
harry's
dot com slash h3
thank you thank you
you know that was good
how we go how long i mean can i talk
about anything else we've been going for
an hour and ten minutes
oh [ __ ] this is all we've talked about i
kind of like the dedication
you know oh no
we got the little nas music video which
i mean these people are so ridiculous
they're getting upset about this like
dude
how are people trish is one of them
actually funnily enough
but i that's what i said to trisha i was
like you're just being superstitious you
just are grown up to
feel like satanic and devil imagery
makes you is like
something's bad is gonna happen but like
have you seen one these christians
speaking in tongue
like this [ __ ] is way creepier than
not working on that on the satan
and by the way isn't what that what the
christians think like he goes to hell
and twerks on satan isn't that what they
think goes on and now
as far as i'm aware this is an accurate
portrayal of what they think happened
i don't know if they preach uh that
there is
dancing and twerking in hell well okay
but he's [ __ ] you're in the wrong
it's not like he's [ __ ] god he's not
like saying g
like dev if not that would be big let's
say if homosexuality's a sin
the devil's probably gay because he
embodies like sin and that and so the
devil probably
is gay why are you gay
right right like that's a rational
argument to make so
so like this is good this is what they
want this is what they think gay people
he goes to hell and he talks on the
devil that's it that's what they that's
ex
as the world should be in their view so
who is gay
i don't know i don't know anymore
is the devil gay i know nas is gay
lil naz is gay and i got news for you
that means you're gay
hmm the devil's gay
i mean they've made jokes about this for
years i mean in movies and stuff like
what little nikki was like 20 years ago
and they were shoving like a pineapple
up hitler's ass
and uh of that maybe we did oh south
park was great with satan was gay
and [ __ ] saddam hussein
right yeah they're so annoying people
are just so pathetic
dude talking in tongues is literally
satanic
creepy [ __ ]
you are literally if anyone's channeling
satan it's you
they go excuse me have you seen little
nas new video where he twerks on satan
oh
so terrified their eyes
that's creepy everyone's losing their
mind
holy ghost oh blood of the lamb bloody
that [ __ ] makes me way more
uncomfortable
you seen these [ __ ] like
striking down the demons and i'm like
oh by the blood
these christians are out of their
[ __ ] mind
con also they're taking the bait let's
be honest
yeah big bad free victory such
such bait i love i actually like lil
naus x
he is he's been like associating with
james charles which i don't know what
the [ __ ] that's about i'm assuming he
doesn't know
but his music videos always slap and it
seems like a good how
has he been associating with james
charles oh he was doing tech talks with
him
they they had a yeah they did a youtube
video together on james's channel
oh well then we hate a little not sex
now
but this was november it's been a minute
well november was kind of
in exposed territory
that's right listen lila's ex needs to
know too we got to call him out too does
little nos x know that he promoted the
wrong gummies
is he aware the wrong way the wrong
gummies
vitamin gummies yeah yeah that might
change his perspective
he's stealing that yeah that might sway
him more than the predator thing
the most recent one was december 18th
so that was pretty recent yeah
and look it's it's it sucks because i
like him
it's just like why are you doing this
the little naz x
you gotta assume that most people don't
i pay attention to this stuff
yeah yeah yeah the drama well tick tock
sure the tick tock literally doesn't let
you talk about it so
that's a huge portion of the people that
follow him
i mean tick tock is our home little nas
is [ __ ] hilarious on tick tock he's
so funny he's such
i'm i'm i'm a fan he's literally cracks
me up on tick tock
he's the funniest [ __ ] dude he's pretty
epic on twitter too
yeah i see the responses you see his
response to the gun girl
oh yeah we have that in here dude this
[ __ ] is so funny
love that dude yeah
you gotta let lil by the way i was
typing his name out
the other night we were prepping for the
show and it were corrected a little
christmas and i thought that was funny
little xmas made me a chuckle
anybody christmas stuff
fair enough not the right season for
that joke melania forgive me
keep me freaked you're right she's right
let's stick with wild mosaics
um yeah he he had some slam dunks on
some of these dumb dumbs
let's see right wing pastor greg is not
a fan of little nausea
this is this is like an old one the from
the you know who little nash x was
this is from the last time i forget even
why they were mad at him the last time
they're saying he's satanic
whoever you know i had no idea who he
was he was writing this morning hudson
said well you know who what made him
famous i said well
you know he was that horse's side got my
horses in whatever that song i was like
man that's all you got a cool beat i'll
never be able to listen to it again a
bunch of devil worship and wicked
nonsense pentagram wearing on your nike
tennis u666 you think i won't stand for
that you've lost your
what's this guy imagine how he feels
about the new video this guy got
triggered over him riding a horse
no he is talking about the new one yeah
this is about the new oh okay
okay he's talking about the shoes
because it's 666 on the shirt
okay okay wait let me listen to this
[ __ ] again he's so charged up
love it he's selling tickets tonight boy
that little nuts ex sermon
tonight we talk about lil knows x
save our children our children watch
that little niles x video once and then
second dick the next day damn it
and you know what happened with gay
sucked it we get hurricanes and
earthquakes
every natural disaster
these people are [ __ ] cuckoo and we
actually listen to them like there's
people that listen to them in our
country and they vote
a lot of them they go three victory
victims people think that gay people
cause hurricanes and they
vote okay that should terrify you
it's not great do you see um there's a
viral post going around on twitter
saying uh it was like a graph showing
a church attendance yeah i heard about
that it's like below 50
for the first time ever in this country
listen and it's happened in the last
like decade it's like a
insane fall off listen i'm not
anti-religion you know i'm not
anti-spirituality i just think that
people like these really uh
culti christians and in general i think
people who
tend to flock to organizations
uh religion tend to just have
really toxic social beliefs
oh jesus you know
so that's what i don't like about it i
have no problem with christianity or
jews or muslims or anything i mean you
know what i mean god bless do whatever
you think whatever it is
just saying if you think sucking dick
cause hurricanes then you're an [ __ ]
and an idiot what are we going to do you
know
little thug whoever you know i had no
idea this morning hudson said well you
know what made him famous i said well
you know he was at home this video just
stuttery is this yeah
it's yeah the video itself is okay yeah
but he's
also stuttering i i get that partner i
meant the video
yo those flames are lit in the
background by the way is that holy
flames
uh i don't that looks like hellfire to
me dude
hard to tell the difference like some
[ __ ] artists
[Music]
that can that's really loud
those flames are like
the difference between holy flame and
health flame is just one
hair one [ __ ] hair
you suck in it or you hmm
don't you put that [ __ ] in your mouth
boy satan i said don't you put that
[ __ ] in your mouth now you stop that
fear
as you know there's a biblical story
about
abraham who defied god by putting a [ __ ]
in his mouth
i must have missed that chapter
i wasn't in my torah portion yeah right
because there's really nothing about gay
people i don't know why they're so
obsessed with it
i was like man that's all you got a cool
beat i'll never be able to listen to it
again a bunch of devil worshipping
wicked nonsense pentagram wearing on
your nike tennis you six six six you
think i'm moving
you tell a little dash x i said so
satanism bunch of wickedness touching
devilism bunch of demonism a bunch of
psychotic weakness
he's like i love that [ __ ] cowboy
[ __ ] was a bop
but now i'm out
[Music]
oh i just saw on my on twitter chat
hanks
were we talking about this on screen or
off screen about the whole chet
hanks thing because uh we haven't talked
about it on the show
we were talking before the show started
about chet hanks tom hanks son who
started the whole white
boy summer thing um
and this [ __ ] does not look good
somebody said unfortunately the merchant
looks aggressively racist
i actually have to agree for some reason
that's just not something i would
ever wear pussycloth if i saw someone
wearing that i'd be like um
a coming back a family knows that guy's
not someone i want to know
damn especially with the neck the neck's
not helping
[Music]
really try to capitalize on his moment
white voice has he been talking about
like how did he get this out so far you
know what he needed
for this to be non-threatening is like a
hawaiian shirt
i'm like aggressively white [ __ ] he
he was very explicit in one of his
videos about whiteboard summer
just to give a little context since the
audience might not be aware but
he's promoting this idea that this
summer is is white boy summer
where is this on twitter or or instagram
it's been on his instagram
all right let's let's just go to the
horse's mouth as they say the white
boy's mouth
yeah and um coming back a family news up
you know people were kind of on board
for white boys summers surprisingly
it's been getting so where's a lot of
transition but it was a car video i
remember
he's been yeah bro he's jack what's up
chet
he's been talking about it for a bit now
chet bro people are joking about how
like the diversity of tom hanks nuts is
incredible
it is it's amazing the the ecosystem
that exists in israel
oh you send me a link i'm already on
this link
okay where's the white boy summer one
sorry i sent around there okay thank you
so here is white boy summer shout out
now shout out to the chat
shout out to the island big up ethan
from h3 the japanese underwater
white boy summer going up it's fantastic
i love to see it
thanks for making that a thing uh you
know genesis
that's not the original this is the
aftermath here ian ian just
sent the chet hanks updates a twitter
account
[Music]
okay what am i gonna do with this ian
chet hank
update well i think it's all nothing but
love and good vibes taught
everyone that's what the
update says oh chat here what's up guys
top of the morning to you top of the
morning to you
okay so check this out you see we
dropped something for the morning yo get
it straight well you're top of the
morning you can't be dropping top of the
mornings and island vibes
well i don't know why ireland is an
island
right okay it is and a former colony of
the united kingdom so there's sort of a
there's sort of a kinship with jamaica
that's a stretch but i'll take it
yeah white boys summer everybody knows
that the irish are a minority
chet hanks and intentionally becoming a
white nationalist icon
it's so [ __ ] all right you found the the
original one thank you here it is
yeah this was going mega viral on
twitter hey guys um
look i just wanted to tap in really
quick i just got this feeling man
um that this summer is uh
it's about to be a white boy summer you
know
take it how you want i'm not talking
about like trump uh
you know nascar type white i'm talking
about you know
you know me um john b
jack harlow type white boy summer you
know what i mean let me know if you guys
uh
can vibe with that and get ready
you know because i am i by the way he is
he is for the record made videos saying
trump is a [ __ ] clot i believe he said
so he
called him a pussycloth right that was
about trump so
he's definitely not a white nationalist
or anything like that but
i'm afraid this is gonna go horribly
wrong for him
[ __ ] them russ
[Music]
yeah this is what this is white boy
summer
this is like the kind of vibe i want
from white boys
maybe something i don't want to watch
gothic
you know oh here's rolls and rags okay
this is important wow this
is rules and wrecks this is very
important let's get it straight
woke up this morning internet gone mud
again um i can't
drive a few uh rules and rags for
the white boy somewhere okay rule number
one uh to all my white boys out there
no plaid shirts okay can't be looking
like a picnic table out here right right
taking notes uh you know what i'm
talking about leave that shit's at home
the uh vineyard vines and
you know chad has no shirts just
straight up nose shirts
[ __ ] plaid ralph lauren or whatever the
[ __ ]
leave that [ __ ] at home uh just put on a
black tea a white tea you know what i
mean
keep it simple uh rule number two no
sperry top ciders
that's right not the kind of white boys
we're talking about dog wait what is
this berry
there's a stupid boat uh-oh ian what are
you doing
throwing your plaids out oh no oh
see ya ian is officially joining the
white boy
summer you know more you got to get
yourself some white and black teas even
i think what you're wearing now is too
it's a little too colorful too colorful
i mean with peace and love i don't know
that's what i think backward hats are
good
dad hats are iffy
i'm i don't know man i gotta i think i
have to take this one to trial
i don't think i'll ever be down with the
backward hat
that's that's where i'm getting the
durst vibes big time yeah dude
i don't know that i can ever get down
with the backward hat chat
right i mean some it's okay sometimes
never but
but like required never what's the point
of wearing a [ __ ] hat
what if what if like your employee like
has a really bad haircut
so they just like you were getting
slammed this episode holy [ __ ]
well i guess yeah no i don't like it i
feel like i look like i'm like 12 years
old
so i agree i don't think it's a terrible
look
i don't like it i'm sorry i wasn't
targeting you i know i'm just i'm
totally kidding
i know the comments would say but he
says
he says dead hats are iffy someone put a
fourth prop position we ban
all backwards hat i shut that [ __ ] down
real quick backward hats
are and will remain good so
there's apparently some kind of conclave
some kind of uh well it seems like it
and there may be a conclave but they
don't hold any actual uh
political sway this is a top down thing
yeah he's a monarch yeah
true oh here okay interesting more
discord on the dad hat
we are getting very close to banning dad
hats
but there are some exceptions if an
individual has a clean
fade he may rock a dead at
bro i'm not even sure about this whole
fade thing you know like what i gotta
have a fade to be white boy summer i
mean
bro what are you talking about this is a
lot
you gotta have a curved bra i mean this
is a lot you guys
if you want to rock or dad hat do the
work and find a good barber
he says seventh amendment i think we're
getting weirder and weirder the deeper
we go here
respect personal space at parties
especially while drunk
i mean just the summer or like all the
time
i think that should that should just
stand beyond that's a good rule just
for all year round stay the [ __ ] away
from annual i'm not going to read this
i'm not going to break that right down
uh
flip-flops are good okay
oh there you go abe you were wearing
some slides right i'm starting to lose
i'm starting to bro what the [ __ ] is
this
this is i didn't know this a sandal with
a bottle opener on the bottom what kind
of degenerate words are these
i have a pair of those dude this is the
most degenerate [ __ ]
ever zach have you ever used it like for
a girl if she has
to open her beer or something no no no
no
why didn't you actually [ __ ] have you
ever used them to open a bottle
well yeah i mean using yeah just not for
a girl but this is the idea of
lifting your foot you don't want to put
the foot anywhere near
the little seems so tragic if you wear
them on the beach i mean you walk
barefoot on the beach
no but it's the thought of yeah but your
shoe
you're not touching the what you're
putting your lips on yes you are
yeah it's not even the it's not the
sanitary issue it's the traffic
look if you need a bottle opener you
need a bottle dude i could see zach
waiting for like three summers
yeah and someone's like oh you got a
bottle opener's like oh
yeah he wears those just wait look if
you're on a [ __ ] boat and you need a
bottle opener i mean i'm your guy
with my [ __ ] i'm sure it's convenient
yeah who's going out to drink on a boat
and doesn't bring a bottle opener let's
get real
it doesn't make sense you'd be surprised
or at least like a lighter you could do
like the the lighter party trick you
know why why would i want to do that if
i'm wearing the bottle opener
because the lighter isn't on the
computer i'm gonna be straight with you
with peace and love
somebody rolls up with these and
they are opening bottles with these
what i'm gonna probably think less of
them
i'm gonna think less of them like i know
you and i love you zach so i don't think
less of you
well i hope you don't think less of me
that would deeply hurt me
no i could never think less of you but
i'm just saying i'm just saying
my perception of these sandals is like
wow
i i i love you zach so i would never
think that i mean i love
i love about you that you have these
sandals
but anyone else you would think less
yeah because i don't know them so it's
like a prejudiced thing
okay but i know i appreciate it you're
one of the good ones zach yeah
yeah i appreciate it like a moratorium
or a yeah but what do they what does
chet think that's what's most important
what's not good are the [ __ ] little
funky ass [ __ ] rainbows
and reef ones with bottle openers on the
bottom
and we got that friend that wears those
funky ass flip-flops with everything
dude
nighttime daytime and pants yo flip-flop
with pants is a true fashion crime i
have to say
none of you guys do that right oh i
special
flip flops with long pants is a fashion
nightmare for
me with sweatpants and some slides
i love different yeah i feel like i've
seen you wear that many times
me and yeah no ethan
you're the socks in sandals yeah i don't
know if you can really dude for me
jeans with flip-flops like where the g
yeah i mean that's bad
i agree with you but i just rocked that
[ __ ] yeah of course you did the gene
goes
under the foot when they watch it it's a
craziest look
i rock that [ __ ] man bro you can't yeah
no everybody's judging you you have to
know that look i'm confident that i
rocket hawaiian shirts and nice
every time i go to florida i'm rocking
that but thank you
the pants are fitted
listen i'm not like a fashionable guy by
any means
but so who am i i disagree with that
statement
no i don't know i think you're
self-aware in anything you do
bro i just for me this the the jeans
under the
sandals crazy look and then they are all
torn from being walked on you know
it's like people need to hem their jeans
like they need to be tapered well yeah
you're gonna go to the tailor so that
you can rock yourself
then maybe you could pull it off that's
what i do
damn i didn't know you're so posh
that's pretty badass rocking my reefs no
birkenstocks
i agree nah the birkenstocks no bud
light we're just banning beverages now
do not cheap out on alcohol chet
no he's right about that too well chet i
mean listen
he's got money you can't be banned wait
he's not banning bud light he's banning
natty ice
yeah natty ice [ __ ]
all right i think i'm getting too deep
to be honest with you guys
it's a lot of rules i'm learning a lot
learning a lot about myself
there's a 13th amendment keep noise
levels down
this goes hand in hand with getting too
drunk guys we got to keep the noise
level down
i know like every time you take a shot
it feels really good just go
whoo okay
[Laughter]
well you don't have to scream all right
let's take dude we've been talking about
chat longer than james charles at this
point
we were actually in the middle of
talking about little nos x when we sort
of got sidetracked
into this well let's quickly look at his
story let's see
black queen summer whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa is it black no
this has been part of
them this has been part of it from the
beginning
he's all about the black queens but he
said it was black queen
year so i mean he's got to make up his
mind
but the summer is a part of the year
we got it it doesn't really it doesn't
really preclude
we've got to update the other seasons
what's up guys top of the morning see
the top of the morning to you
okay so check this out you see we
dropped the merch we got the black queen
summer merch coming today
and uh i consulted with a great white
boy summer spirit
and he said hey dude old english writing
is sick i know that's your style and
everything but
like can you see how some people might
take it the wrong way like it like it's
too aggressive
and i said yeah yeah you got a point so
we're dropping the stop hate edition
where it's just going to say white voice
armor and stop hate in big ass bold
letters across the back
so we're dropping that along with the
black queen summer merch
that's going to be today you know white
boy summer's all about positivity
inclusivity everybody love everybody so
we just don't want people getting the
wrong idea about that
even though the old english writing does
look dope
apart from that there's a bunch of top
and compiling
hmm i see and i wear the white boy
summer with the stop the hate
on the front what's the weight let's see
here
where's the stop the hate i saw it it
was yeah it was on that
white boy summer just go back to the
main page
where's this it was just there it's all
right so you removed it or what
no it's under blood like queen summer
why they put why are they hiding that
under black queen
summer little sauce it is a little sauce
you got to put that in the white boy
collection
i mean nobody's wearing this one let's
be honest chad but it's a good call
it's white boy summer stuff
let's see you can get the lagging i love
when people make leggings they're like
yeah throw the leggings in
like okay someone's buying leggings from
chat hanks no
nobody's buying leggings from chat eggs
like that's such a specialized item you
can't just
throw out leggings that says white boy
summer on it all right that's enough of
that
are we all clear on the rules
said all these comments are just thirst
trapping let me see
i like him okay thanks
bravo dude getting in shape love you
fire flames definitely wipe what yeah
it's just so it is a lot of thirst trap
um peace what's that
lenny kravitz that was i thought that
was lenny
all right that was a lot anyway you i
was talking about a little
snacks but you get it these people are
idiots
they're creepy
and then what there was uh the satan
shoes
he's getting sued by nike so i would not
want to get sued by nike trust me on
that
majority of the blame is going to the
company though not right yeah
but he's goofing on it i wonder if
they're like oh doing it down
all right they're gonna get [ __ ] in
the ass nike's like one of the most
powerful companies in the world
you know some guy tried to do oh it
wasn't some guy was
i was just trying to remember didn't we
have trump's dumb ass lawyer
or no no no what's the other guy it was
a lawyer
avenatti god it was such a weird four
years
that [ __ ] idiot michael he's in jail
all right yeah he's in jail
he tried to extort nike and they called
the fbi and his ass was in jail by the
end of the [ __ ] day
you remember there was a minute there
where people wanted him to run for
[ __ ] president
yes i do dan people were all about
avenatti
he's a [ __ ] jail fraud trying to
extort 25 million from nike
they're like uh sure dude they called
the fbi
and he was in jail like before the phone
was down
and they also he got in a ton of trouble
he had stolen a ton of money from his
own clients
like he would win lawsuits and then
pocket the money himself and just not
give
money to his clients good guy so i
actually did think it was an official
collab when i saw them
so i was like oh god nike's in down to
put drops of blood in the soul
[Laughter]
so the concept is that
it's red ink with one drop of blood i
was like that's insane that's nike's
down for that
it doesn't seem like sanitary seems like
a biohazard well it turns out
they're not they're not yeah they're not
they are not down they're making six six
six of them it's all satanic
so but the thing is that actually i
think might actually make it legal
unfortunately for nike but they'll
definitely try this in court
is that it's a limited run there's six
six six of them
and it's not like widely distributed
it's an art piece
in collaboration with this company that
does
this kind of art um
and they've done stuff like this before
so i actually think that they're
probably gonna win this
this legal case well i mean how much
money do they have to fight nike
well they're a huge company
the company that made these shoes the
thing is they're a thousand dollars a
piece
and they made 666 they're going to spend
a lot more
they're going to spend a lot more money
in court
than they do and that's what i mean like
making money even if they have a valid
argument i mean
the the thing when you get sued by a
company like nike they can just bury you
in legal fees it doesn't even matter if
you're right
yeah i'm really curious how the legal
case goes out because usually they'll
just settle
but i don't know how you settle this
because they're still selling the shoe i
mean they already sold the show
right maybe they just god what would
nike want them to do
so interesting they don't want damages i
mean
they have no interest in money they prob
what
what can they do i mean at this point
they've already they probably just feel
like the lawsuit itself is
the point because it's performative
because of the whole the whole backlash
about these shoes they don't want to be
seen as individuals
they probably actually don't give a [ __ ]
right and as we mentioned on frenemies
they've done it in the past and received
no legal action
when they did one for jesus she made an
angel one right because nobody was up in
arms about it
that's awesome but yeah if they don't
react to this then
they get you know lumped in with all
these other they actually lose sales
from the speaking in tongues people
nike is the devil
burn your nikes burn your nikes
yeah these were the ones that got no
action we love
the holy water shoes those are [ __ ]
lame compared to the double ones i'm
sorry
[Music]
yeah they said it's like holy water from
spain
was that a little nos thing or just a
different no that was just with them
[Music]
so why it's only fair if we're talking
about inclusivity
why the [ __ ] god get a shoe and double
doesn't get a shoe what are we going to
do
sounds like some racist [ __ ] devil
gets his shoe double gets his dude devil
gets his shoe
that's right anyway
um i think you're right it's
performative and they'll probably settle
out of court
on something trivial and it probably
won't matter
right can we talk about the fact that uh
ian predicted all of this
all right two years ago yeah let me pull
this up in the profit
um ian please stand up
you're gonna have to highlight it for me
i don't see it it's at the top
in in i can't keep standing up
stand up i haven't seen you stand up
once the president demands it
ian please stand up all right all right
i'm out
am i going to get what's with this music
wait this is our video this is our video
i don't think we're going to get going
we made this yes
or ian's legendary slideshow yeah
[Music]
ian what the [ __ ] bro where's this [ __ ]
i want this from you
this is so epic what is this i never
forgot about this actually
this is so good come on man where is the
power points
people think i'm like trying to keep you
down cause like they go i swear to god i
read comments with hundreds of likes
they go
ethan's just mad that ian's funnier than
him and so he
intentionally keeps him off the air
that's like a big conspiracy
i'm begging ian all the time to please
make more content
that's all you can't force it people
it's like when ian comes up with the
funny concept he does it
you know it's just like if you if you
force it it's it's gonna
it's gonna be
one of the four beasts saying come and
see
and i saw and behold a white horse
and behold a pale horse and his name
that said on him
was death and hell followed with him
what the [ __ ] was that
narrating that
i'm going to take my horse to the old
town road
bro i can tell i can't know more i'm
going to take my horse
to the old town road ride until i can't
know more
i'm going to take my horse to the old
town road
right until i can't know more until i
can't
no more so here's the cover with uh so
well this is like a 14-minute clip yeah
no no we
that was the main thing we wanted to
show just and the date of this is august
uh 2019.
yeah you you and did a whole powerpoint
presentation on
right the prophet over here he's come
out but that was a good call ian
how does it feel to be right i think i
had just found a video by some guy who
said that lil nossex was a satanist
and the video had like 70 views
and i built the powerpoint around that
uh that guy
he's he's right that guy's feeling
stoked right now
yeah he's in his abatements he's in his
somewhere or
speaking tongues to a crowd of people
by the blood of the lamb dude that's so
[ __ ]
[Music]
the blood of the lamb it's like whoa
dude
i'd rather give satan a lap dance by
bathing the blood of the lamb by the
blood of the lamb
it's like whoa the cargo ship this [ __ ]
cracked me up like seriously bro how the
[ __ ] do you [ __ ] up
this shit's resolved wait i want to see
the people
yeah they got it but like i gotta have
it like a quarter of the world's trade
was stuck in this
just tell me how to say it canal the
name of the canal
the suez suez thank you just say it for
me
half the world or like a quarter of the
world's trade was stuck because this
[ __ ] idiot literally drove his boat
sideways in a canal
it's like you you idiot
i they said it was because of wind like
no
okay i've been wondering if there's been
a full investigation because i
i feel my instinct was that he did this
intentionally like disgruntled employees
because it's just hard to explain
otherwise right but
i could be i you know maybe it was some
weird thing
15 of those of the world's uh trade
thank you baby
i think i think the captain was
celebrating white boy summer he was
having a good time
is this i feel like this is in violation
well i think he's a little ahead of
schedule
too it's only march it's not white boy
summer yet we're getting ready for
whiteboard summer dude this but like i
feel like if you wanted to do this
on purpose this would be an incredible
feat to actually
stick the boat and fully block the canal
well the canal authority chairman said
that
it's not just off the weather he goes
there's definitely some humor and
error in there oh yeah well and then
this boat weighs like a billion tons as
the gust of wind is not gonna
push it into shore and then do you know
about the the elements of the um
the ship had drawn a penis shape before
this happened
stop i'm not kidding you hadn't seen
this
you're [ __ ] with me i'm not [ __ ]
with you hold on he's on the t right now
he has a massive penis
excuse me it makes it even hotter i do
love tiny penises
i'm waiting so you think the captain
just was trying this one's for 4chan
kind of vibe
right yeah maybe um here i'm trying to
find one
the captain was an incel from fortune
here's the picture
i i think i am here i'm sending you the
picture right now
i'm weighing okay it's coming
i'm watching discord i'm just looking at
discord
there it is thank you this is like the
nautical describe what i'm looking at
well so this is like the the nautical
like record of its path
and and look before it hit it starts at
the bottom
now it's off screen this is prior to
getting to the
next is this abnormal boat oh sure i
mean
why are you trying well i don't know
if it's this is just you know what i
mean you could take it out of context
that's it i mean i am not up to speed a
maritime
uh procedure or law or really anything
having to do with most real
this is real yeah yeah oh
thank you wendy yeah all of the um
so same as like with airplanes there's
all these public websites where you can
like
track all the world's boats but wouldn't
so it seems like a boat that size would
take quite a long time to chart a penis
like someone must have known like what
is going on here
right and so it did this and then drove
into the canal and jammed itself
in sideways it just seems like
somebody was having a bad day i don't
know but dude this is the best thing
ever but they
they got her ass uh they got her you
know someone said
actually someone's out of there but yeah
they they tugged it out but there was
actually
footage if you guys recall uh hidden
footage of this
uh disaster happening and i'm trying to
unstick it
i don't know if you guys have seen this
oh my god
oh my god
oh i missed the gatsby
dude getting on the elevator this
weekend was a nightmare
yeah baby got to ride the gatsby for the
first time
i don't remember i don't i don't know if
you remember me getting it in there
but i like had the full throttle through
the door
oh i remember it's the hardest i've ever
seen you laugh
before or since
like by a long shot like it's not even
close
it was so shocking because i had a hard
impact and made it through
and then the second impact just shocked
me and was so powerful the second wheel
busting through the door we [ __ ] that
building up so bad
you had the mailman riding too right we
did it
man i can't wait to how was your
experience on the gatsby av
oh it was awesome i it was a lot faster
than i expected
yeah it catches you off guard i thought
it wouldn't impress me because i have my
boosted board but it seemed
pretty like we got a premium we got a
premium
i've warned a ton of people too like the
the famous bobby lee incident i told him
over and over again
it's way faster than you you just take
it easy mobility i kept telling him you
should practice with it first he's like
no i don't need to practice and then he
almost
[ __ ] killed himself that was the last
time anyone ever
drove that thing for the podcast i
thought for sure he was done
it's scary are you
scared because it takes off are you guys
down for real if we do a company event
at disney if i take the gatsby
i when when we went to disney last time
i was like looking at you every time i'm
like gotta get on this disability
mobility action
dude that what if we all got one
like legit if we all i'd be so obnoxious
they would [ __ ] hate
us i would do that
i would totally pay for that you buy us
all mobility standards
if there was just a trade of gatsby
there were
at least it's the gang i feel like we
could do it too because you just pay
money
for the vip and they'll let you do
whatever you want
dude imagine that yeah
everywhere
i feel like we could actually do that it
would ruin it
it totally would ruin the whole park
everybody in the whole park would be
talking about it
the whole park the whole world would
talk about it it goes super viral
we can do that what would that cost me
30 000 and i mean yeah how much they
were like four
it was like four grand so 40 000
and
i mean that's pretty and then the the
tour itself cost
[ __ ] i just realized the gatsby is meant
to look like a rolls royce
look like a train no no
it's supposed to look like a classical
[ __ ] you're right
the grill is yeah the girls i thought it
was like a 20s car and the emblem
honestly considering that we should try
it to see if we can do this
that would feel so bad yeah i would feel
really bad because we would also
we were ruining this morning no
no it'd be like a main street parade for
eight hours
not only do we cut in every line we just
slamming back
through all the crowds in our guests
excuse me it has a horn
in the horn out of the way oh we have to
get one for the
tour guide too to keep up with us sure
yeah
[Music]
what are you showing me that it's a
rolls-royce oh what is no this one
this is these ones are only 2k oh dude
it's got to be the gatsby he's gotta be
the guy that's great
okay i thought you'd be like our leader
on the no hopefully yeah
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's just a chair like screwed onto a
hoverboard
there would be such a pain to get there
too we'd have to ship them to dinner
like a trailer or flatbed you have to
get like a whole like race car
trailer fill them up
or like a whole tow i would do it i
would do it i'll spend a hundred
thousand dollars
through this they're 4k
oh my gosh yeah so 4k
each that's 40 000.
the tour would probably cost
at least like 10 15 000. jesus
the tow truck i don't know that's i have
no idea what that will cost
i'd have to buy one for the tour guide
too that's 11. so add another 4k
[Music]
you just rat speed day rental no you
think we can rent them
we'd be
that would be the funniest day
of our lives it'd be the quickest trip
to disneyland we would finish the
park let's go to pirates
just the attention the intrigue
the logistics of like pulling into some
of those areas with ten of them
like it would just be such a [ __ ]
yeah there's that area right outside um
like the haunted mansion it's always
like shoulder to shoulder
just parking all dead would have to be
parked up on the grass
all ten of us hockey
if you ever become like okay
you ask why warren buffett doesn't give
his money away it's so he can
keep the [ __ ] like this in his pocket
so that he can visit disneyland with a
bunch of gatsbys
so say you don't want to sacrifice
you need to hold on to your wealth for
when opportunities like this come along
right it would be some legendary [ __ ] i
have
okay i'm gonna write them an email and
see
we can't we can't do this come on oh
yeah i'm
serious oh my god
one of us would email i'm gonna say i i
need to be a visual
and let's be real one of us will
definitely slam into a tourist
yeah yeah if somebody's gonna get hurt
probably
i write the emails say i have 10
people of disabled people
i need to be happy for 10 disabled
people
[Laughter]
they would feel bad saying no so they
would definitely accommodate it but then
when we all show up totally normal
they probably wouldn't know what to do
all right let's get on them
like if it was one or two they wouldn't
say anything but like 10 totally
normally
oh god american disability act they
can't ask questions i'm gonna have lena
look into it
don't do this although disneyland's
probably pretty desperate right now
they've been closed for a year right so
maybe they will be down fun as [ __ ]
i'm gonna write them an email just wait
wait wait didn't tom cruise do something
like where he rented out the park
for like his kids dude that's gotta cost
like a hundred million dollars
like the amount of money they generate
in a day is insane
that's true i mean they do do private
rentals of the park
really how much does that cost oh that's
out of my league but that's warren
buffett [ __ ]
right and it's usually like a huge
corporation
it's gotta be like 20 million bucks or
something
it's i think it's going to be one of
those things you have to call in yeah
they don't have a breath
on that so you can rent out
just for reference six flags for a
hundred thousand dollars an hour
who cares about six flags so it's got to
be like 100 times that it's not quite as
big as disneyland but it
it's 100 000 an hour i could just
disrupt the whole [ __ ] day and kick
everyone out for an hour there's got to
be a minimum
oh and they usually do it at night like
i went to one of these things
for my graduation from high school like
the entire
high school paid for that well not just
one high school it was like lausd
it was like the whole l.a yeah i did
that too right they rented it
bro don't they need that pencils and
[ __ ] jesus i'm sorry i touched the cable
everything okay yeah it's fine bro they
spent like a million dollars for you
guys to go to six flags don't kids like
not have power it was disneyland there
wasn't
six flags what was the night called dan
it was called
this just called grad night or something
brad knight wait do you guys see what's
wrong with this grad night thing like
kids are like starving at school and
y'all are partying at disneyland i mean
it's possible
it's possible that disneyland did it as
a charity thing maybe for the schools
let's hope that's the case because they
are you know
it's it's the local school district
essentially you know
i had to pay i had to pay for it oh
maybe we did have to pay oh yeah see i
remember that yeah you pay for
everything
they just say oh only grads can go
but like like after like midnight when
the park technically closes
you're allowed to have access on rides
right big bro
yeah yeah that's pretty cool yeah it was
like an all-nighter
i'm gonna write them an email oh boy and
let's just see where the conversation
goes
i'm gonna say i have ten how do i write
this in a way that sounds
i mean that's possible it sounds
plausible it's just
yeah what there's no private tours for
a group of disabled people we all have
no i'm sure they'll buy it they're just
going to be pissed as [ __ ] when we show
up and it's us
i have no doubt that they would arrange
it banned from disneyland
so renting out one ride for
four hours is 50 grand i just want to
see the headlines
do we have to do it i mean disneyland
can we find it funny or they'd be best
i don't want to get into like a
controversy over it yeah
yeah but you know people all
think it's so funny
there'll be pictures of us in tmz let's
see what the rea
yeah probably this is just the reaction
let's see how the uh how the audience
reacts to this idea and maybe we can
judge from there disability mobility
well now's a good time because there are
25
capacity so like i would i do worry
about those huge crowds because we could
get stuck in one
place for like an hour right but with 25
capacity it could be a perfect time for
this
oh sheesh by the way uh we're we're at
like two hours and 20 minutes on this
episode
all right let's wrap it up thank you
guys for watching let us know what you
think about our idea
i'm leaning yes but tell me what you
think
um this is in lieu of you guys getting
bonuses this year by the way okay i'm
definitely against the idea now
i'm gonna i'll take the cash i'll take
the gatsby ride man that's okay
man how many people say that in their
lifetime
they wrote it who can say they gotta
that that's that's that is stuff to tell
your [ __ ] grandkids exactly
dan the hater all right thanks for
watching guys
we'll see you on friday for live
after dark live with ela everybody loves
elo see you then